et pour en parler nous sommes avec elle
un patel président de l'association
médicale franco asiatique bonsoir alain
cataye merci d'être avec nous conseil de
sécurité donc de l'onu en urgence à new
york pour le moment aucune information
n'a filtré à quoi doit-on s'attendre aux
soient les suites cette réunion je crois
que la chine et la russie ont leur veto
il y aura sûrement de bonnes résolutions
mais je crois qu'il ya deux choses ce
soir qui sont très importantes sait déjà
que le gouvernement en exil de sierre ph
qui est le seul gouvernement normalement
élu a promulgué la nouvelle constitution
du pays et ceux ci il ya quelques heures
c'est un événement formidable car il
avait parfaitement prévu que le 1er
avril il y aurait une nouvelle
constitution qui abolirait la
constitution de 2008 qui donnait un tas
de pouvoir aux militaires
alors les sanctions c'est très bien on
va en parler certainement il faut
étrangler financièrement les militaires
les américains ont pris à des mesures
non pas seulement sur les généraux en
bloquant leurs comptes bancaires
mais sur les conglomérats les deux
grands conglomérats dont tous les
généraux colonels et rotonde et actions
et qui leur permettent d'avoir des
revenus importants c'est pour ça qu'ils
veulent se maintenir au pouvoir
nous on a pas être très fiers en france
parce qu' un certain nombre de
compagnies étrangères ont dit qu'elles
se retiraient de la birmanie des
japonais des coréens est par contre même
nous nous ne devons pas être fier car un
accord le groupe accor hôtelier a dit
qu'il restait en birmanie c'est à dire
il continue à supporter la junte et ce
qui est plus important c'est le groupe
pétrolier total qui exportent ou le gaz
vers la thaïlande et qui verse 250
millions
de dollars par an de taxes à la junte a
dit qu'il ne quitterait pas le pays
ceci n'est pas la gloire des entreprises
françaises
alors vous avez évoqué ces sanctions
notamment prononcé par les etats-unis et
le royaume-uni envers les militaires
mais ans ils n'ont pas vraiment d'effet
ces sanctions comment faire pression sur
eux ben là je ne vous ai pas cité mais
il ya quand même la firme allemande qui
femmes qui donnent tout le papier pour
fabriquer les billets de banque a
immédiatement dit qu'il ne livrer plus
rien c'est à dire que la planche à
billets ne pourra plus fonctionner et
les généraux en rend moins de cash pour
payer les soldes des militaires et les
soldes des policiers il faut employer
tous ses moyens peut-être pas très
glorieux mais pour arriver à faire que
le régime
la junte ce biais du coup d'état les
terroristes qui attaquent la population
n'est plus d'argent n'est plus de cash
ce qui est pas important c'est leur
compte bancaire comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est surtout qui n'est plus
d'argent pour payer l'armée et les
policiers
cela passera forcément par l'argent le
nerf de la guerre
n'djamena par l'argent et tout à l'heure
vous avez cité le rôle des ethnies je
crois qu'il faut parier beaucoup sur les
troupes des ethnies à la frontière de la
chine et de la thaïlande il ya beaucoup
d'ethnies qui ont des forces armées bien
entraînés relative bien équipé et qui
viennent de se rallier massivement aux
protestataires et je crois qu'il faut
aider et financièrement et en leur
fournissant des armes
ces ethnies elles ont commencé à
attaquer des postes militaires et des
postes de police
il faut qu'elle continue et
effectivement on va vers une guerre
civile
à moins que des négociations puissent
venir mais les généraux sont
complètement obtus ils font fi des
déclarations internationales et des
différentes positions
ils seront prises contre eux ils
massacrent la population car dans aucun
pays au monde on voit l'armée tiré à
balles réelles avec des balles à grande
vitesse et avec des fusils à lunettes
carrées ici ils ciblent les têtes et les
temps axe c'est à dire des cibles pour
tuer et ils tuent 35 enfants à un tas de
jeunes qui elles sont révoltés contre la
hiérarchie militaire et ça c'est
absolument scandaleux vous savez le
mouvement je suis pardonnez-moi de
l'armée tire dans les jambes à ces faux
d'habitude l'armée tire dans les jambes
dans tous les pays civilisés quand ils
ont attiré mais jamais dans les têtes et
dans les thorax avec des fusils à
lunettes
c'est à dire pour tuer dans les jambes
je suis chirurgien orthopédiste
on peut réparer et un tuba et quand les
militaires on voit des blessés et les
emmène non pas à l'hôpital mais les
emmène dans les prisons ou dans les
postes de police et malheureusement
lendemain les familles sont priés de
venir chercher les corps
c'est absolument abjecte vous savez en
plus le mouvement de désobéissance
civile a été initiée par les médecins et
les infirmières qui ont déserté les
hôpitaux publics ils se sont repliés sur
les hôpitaux civils où il soigne
gratuitement les blessés et les malades
mais les hôpitaux ont été occupées par
les militaires qui en ont fait leur camp
de base qui est sont des camps situés au
milieu des villes et c'est absolument
scandaleux je sais pas dans quel état on
retrouvera ensuite les hôpitaux
concernés moi mais à l'instant
l'émissaire de l'onu on vient
d'apprendre puisque je vous le rappelle
à le conseil de sécurité réuni en
urgence à new york l'émissaire de l'onu
appelle à utiliser
je suis tous les moyens pour éviter un
bain de sang
c'est vrai que la cct prosélyte comme
déclaration ça veut dire quoi
tous les moyens
est ce qu'on est capable d'envoyer des
casques bleus où des des mercenaires
armés et et un bombarder certains sites
un épi dont la capitale vous savez je
suis sûr que les drones les satellites
américains connaissent au mètre près les
habitations des généraux les véhicules
des généraux etc
mais c'est un acte de guerre je sais pas
si l'onu est prête à à permettre une
ingérence l'ingérence quand les droits
humains sont bafoués peut se concevoir
et c'est conçu dans un certain nombre de
pays
ça serait souhaitable car cette
population est une population pacifique
bouddhiste formidable et qui se fait
massacrer et c'est surtout la jeunesse
qui ce qui est en première ligne et dans
les barricades
car cette jeunesse elle a connu depuis
dix ans l'internet les téléphones
mobiles facebook tout et on les voit la
manu avec des frondes ou des des
catapultes ou même des arcs j'ai vu se
battre contre les militaires ce qu'il
faut bien noter c'est redonner mouallem
l'agente a lancé son coup d'état ensuite
aux élections de novembre 2020 qui selon
eux ont été entachées de d'irrégularités
est ce que ces accusations sont
totalement infondées selon vous obama
selon - oui j'ai a fondé il y avait des
comités de surveillance même
internationaux non ils ont fait le coup
d'état parce que il voyait que le nez le
des avec madame en dessous qui avait
gagné 80% des sièges qu'ils allaient
perdre leur majorité au parlement et que
de fait ils ont 25 % des sièges qui sont
dévolues à l'armée mais qu' il savait
parfaitement que une des premières
choses que fait le nouveau gouvernement
c'est abolir la constitution de 2008 de
faire une nouvelle constitution retirant
une partie des rois de l'armée et
les généraux et les sous les eaux le
grand officier
voyez leur pactole fuir puisque et il
allait perdre là la main mise sur les
entreprises et sur les revenus
car ils sont immensément riche et leur
fortune mais bien souvent dans des
paradis fiscaux
bien cachée par donc oui mais il faut
aider il faut une population et il y
aura sûrement un grand grand projet dead
humanitaire car il va falloir redonner
de l'argent redonner de l'alimentation
et toute cette population qui depuis
deux mois a arrêté de travailler il faut
aider la birmanie merci alain patel je
rappelle que vous êtes un président de
l'association médicale france asiatiques